New Year's Eve next week Huntington New
York the Paramount the first show sold
out I believe the second show was sold
out there's only some tickets left for
the after party if you want to come
doing a little after party with me TT
Jerry Jasmine whatever you want we're
going to be doing a little after party
in Huntington New York at the Paramount
so go to christycomedy.com New Orleans
Civic Theater January 12th Dallas Texas
House of Blues January 13th is sold out
in Houston Texas the House of Blues in
Houston January 14th I believe it's
almost sold out Phoenix Arizona January
26 to the 28th February 22nd Vancouver
British Columbia March 28th 29th West
Palm Beach Florida March 31st Miami
Beach the font on blue and April 12th
Austin Texas christycomedy.com I got a
brand new hour of stand-up material it's
all new if you sit in the front row I do
a little crowd work I probably won't put
a special out for a couple years so come
see this material and have a good time
and also get a sweatshirt get a t-shirt
at chrisdcomedy.com get the merchy where
she let's have a good time let's end
2022 with the bang it's a good gift why
don't you get tickets to my show as a
Christmas gift or a Hanukkah gift or a
Kwanzaa gift why don't you do that do
that and it'll be fun and there's
special guests coming into certain
cities and I'm not going to tell you who
because I haven't thought of them or
contacted them yet
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
and uh
Sal is dead still but he is coming on
next week
um he'll be on actually for the new year
this is the last episode of the year so
we want to end it with Hanukkah but Sal
is coming on
um Sal vulcano will be coming on uh the
first episode of the New Year even
though he's dead he died unfortunately
did die at the end of 2022 but he's
beginning given life in 2023
um like Jesus himself so instead I
thought it would be great
um I saw a great documentary on this
person
um and I loved every minute of it and
I'm so excited that for the very very
last hey babe of the year we have
special guests Weird Al Yankovic I have
nice feet
when you're walking through
neighborhoods like you know like when
you're in Manhattan very trendy cool
like Manhattan this is a trendy area but
do you ever feel that like hair I feel
like
do you ever feel like in these types of
places I love that I'm being dressed
right now yes can I can I put my hand on
you yes you should you're answering for
her this is yeah
yeah that's yeah that's it yeah
all right I'm sorry do my hands smell
like vagina
were you fingering your Uber driver
um
do you ever feel like when you're
walking down the street like you're just
in Ukraine
yeah because there's so many ukrainians
disgusting there's so many Ukrainian
Flags there are I just noticed that you
feel like you're in the gay part of
peanuts
what there's a Ukrainian Church right
near here do you want to jump on it
[Laughter]
I'm the perfect guest because I laugh at
everything you say yeah that's what
everyone said when I did your show the
other day oh yeah but we can't say oh
yeah I mean the show
right but we we're we're told we can't
mention anything about that and uh no
but but Jessica came and did my show
that was on the rice Network
there it is
Jessica
[Laughter]
there it is
look at that bush on Jessica
do you want the hair you don't you know
whatever you want to do
look it
bring your coffee I can't see a thing I
can welcome to the show what happened to
them so is there any oh my God
wait hold on
laughs
and can you hear me yeah can you hear me
this isn't my teeth I'm chewing on this
beard but
you're chewing on this beard oh okay
yeah Jasmine is a beard
he's my beard
it says I'm gay every day she does
sometimes you're not gay no literally
the other night we were just laying in
bed we were watching Yellowstone and she
was like just looking at the ceiling and
she goes Chris are you gay really out of
nowhere because I was jerking off to
Kevin Costner
to James Woods
um so welcome to hey babe Sal will be
coming back um in the New Year okay uh
he's or or we're gonna go live from his
coffin
um so so
um Jessica how uh first of all how uh
how's everything just get Jessica
Jessica
Carson just Jessica Carr said The
Tonight Show with Jessica Carson Jessica
McMahon yes
this is yeah
um so what uh how was the drive-in it
was really annoying I I you know I leave
so early but you know everywhere it's
traffic Long Island yeah it's really
it's it's a lot but it's okay you know
at least I wasn't in an accident that's
why every time I see people in accidents
I'm like they're I didn't get into it
it's fine it's all gonna be fine so I
flipped off 17 people good and I [ __ ] in
my hand and flung it at a couple cars
well so I feel better but you're healthy
so the [ __ ] is good yeah I mean you
should yeah I feel I feel good you know
I've been eating well and um I I feel
really good I'm I'm constipated because
I'm enraged so I hold on to my feces
right so which is the best way to do it
yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm eating a lot of
this beard but I feel like I'm going
down on like an old school lesbian that
doesn't shake like you're going down on
Judy Gold
I don't I don't I've never been with
those kind of lesbians that don't shave
you know I'm into like the really Femme
like they shave their Bush shave their
bushes yeah I'm not into like you know
you got it you gotta be bare or a little
you can have a little but I can't do the
right you know no that's not gonna work
it feels like being a lesbian isn't
enough anymore you have to be something
more than like you just being gay isn't
cool enough well for me it is next level
but you have to has to be a Twist like
what like I don't know like now it's
like you got to be gay but also have one
arm yes like you like you know you can't
just be like the l l g you go that's the
new thing but I'm old school you know me
I'm like I've been out since for 27
years I think yeah I've been out for a
really long really was it hard the first
day coming out to your parents well my
parents knew I mean they were like yeah
what like it was obvi I was with someone
for years and it was I thought it was a
secret but everyone knew because you
would always you were always walking
around with sheetrock
fine and I was crying
was crying I had a girlfriend and I
thought you know of course I thought no
one knew but everyone knew I mean we
were always together and every time she
leave I'd be like bye Melissa
[Laughter]
but it was uh it was hard for me to come
out I always had horrible
um Shame about it I still have stuff
about it if Jasmine's right and I am gay
how how you would know if you're gay how
would you know
Chris I mean do you
I don't I'm looking at the picture of
Tupac Shakur and I want to lick his
teeth no I hate the label gay I'm being
honest with you okay so what should it
be because I watch straight porn and I
like sucking dick you know I say this as
a it's not a joke like I say it as a
joke on stage but I don't mind I haven't
done it in years but I don't mind it
because
I I I liked it like I and I didn't mind
having sex with men I don't have a
desire to do it but I didn't mind it
it's like I just couldn't fall in love
with a man right so I mean I am bi but I
prefer women I don't want to be with men
but I don't find them repulsive I think
men are beautiful I get I I watch porn
with men and women I can watch two men I
can watch two women I whatever right so
I don't think if you're attracted to men
or you get if you get you get hard from
watching a guy or you're gay I I hate
that I hate that yeah like the other
night I think everyone's on some people
never have thought about it once and
then some people think about it but it
doesn't mean it doesn't mean if you're a
guy that you get turned on by it that
you're gay yeah I hate when people do
that and and that's why the other day me
I started like trying to like have sex
with Jasmine because we were watching
the World Cup and Argentina was playing
and Lionel Messi was just running up and
down the field scoring goals and I think
it it just started to make me horny so
what it wasn't him it was just the fact
that he's really good at what he does
That's So that so that can be hot to you
but that doesn't mean yeah yeah so what
like I don't I don't so what that I wish
more people like were okay with that and
didn't have to label it and because I
think a lot of men and women get fearful
of that and go oh my God now I'm gay or
now that's something wrong like that's
not that's actually very human like back
to the beginning of time let me put on
my glasses so I cannot see Jazz said the
only issue she had is while we were
having sex I was demanding that she
allowed me to call her Lionel I get
did you make her run around the yeah and
I made her put on Argentina Jersey and
kicked me in the nuts
and I said bend over Lionel I'm gonna
stick it in your [ __ ]
oh look at this former Nazi worker 97
escapes jail sentence after conviction
for aiding ten thousand five hundred
five murders look at that little old
[ __ ] oh my
500 people because she was a little Nazi
secretary with her beret what do you
think she should be in prison what
should we do she should be tortured they
should do medical experiments they
should torture her yes yes they should
do medical medical I mean you're asking
a Jew like I don't know if I'm the
person to be asking right I feel like
yeah like I mean yes yes she's yeah you
dumb old [ __ ] who cares that she's 97.
yeah well deal with it why she should be
able to live her last year or two in in
peace what did she do she said in the
closing statement she was sorry for what
had happened and regretted sorry so
she'd been there but what did she she
was a stenographer that's what her job
was right she's also 18 when she was
hired so was she groomed by them that's
the debate that they're having she was
18. she she was the stenographer right
and she said she didn't she was just
couldn't she just be a woman who's a
victim of gaslighting
oh God you know what
it's me right now I'm so sick yeah I
wish she was a victim of gas chambering
I
I have gas forget about all this I have
a horrible guests right now because I
ate a lot of cauliflower
yogurt in your coffee
[Music]
I ate a whole bag of cauliflower snacks
because they're quote unquote
cauliflower I am such a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] of [ __ ] do you
eat I've been trying to eat a lot
healthier I've been trying now I've been
really trying hard to just say once a
week and my daughter will always remind
me to only have sweets on Saturdays and
the last two nights the same things
happen I've gotten to about the end of
my fasting window at about 6 p.m and
I've eaten two desserts the both nights
I'm like oh because she's because I'm
like as long as I don't have muffins
because I love muffins in the morning
but I'm like seven months on Saturdays
toasted muffins and butter and jelly the
best Chris you and I have the same taste
I like that because you had scones the
other day one time I took a bite of a
muffin and it was so good I looked my
daughter right in the eye and I said
you're [ __ ] adopted
[Laughter]
just because you ever have to bite into
a food so good you want to throw it
against the wall or hit your mother yes
how many times in the head yeah which
makes a really good roast yeah do you
want to just squeeze someone to [ __ ]
kill them because it's so good I know
that's how I get with my kids sometimes
I bite them and they get so mad they're
like you hurt me I'm like I was hurt too
get over it
yeah one time my mom made the best
lasagna I've ever had in my life and I
threw it down the stairs I said
I said this is why you're lonely Dad was
right and I ran out because the food the
food was so good
[Laughter]
one time my mom made a pot roast and it
was so amazing I smashed it in her head
and told her I'll Never Love Her you
smashing ahead you said guess what mama
[Laughter]
guess what Mom I was assaulted
I was drunk so I think it was my fault
guys
right on right on the YouTube comments
if you've been assaulted
me
adults are buying toys for themselves
and it's the biggest source of growth
for the industry you know what if you're
an adult buying a toy for yourself and
you took it away from a child who wants
that toy you're an [ __ ] I'm talking
to you Joe DeRosa
I loved y'all so I want to find shoulder
pads for Christmas
if you don't do that dude
can you please get huge ones like really
big show like like like those you know
the shoulder pads that used to come in
like the the suits I want to get a
little Hillary Clinton huge ones like a
and a deep purple jacket oh God what'd
you get the kids for Christmas you
didn't what didn't we get it's amazing
to you know Danielle will say to me
don't leave a light on and then there's
thousands of dollars being spent on
Christmas gifts I'm like what the [ __ ]
this reminds me of my grandmother who is
very wealthy dad don't you better drink
your diet coke I spent money on that
Diet Coke and then would spend tons of
money on other things the priorities are
[ __ ] up to you as a Jewish person but
your kids are half Jewish half
Christians well they're not the Jewish
part goes out the [ __ ] window with
the holidays that means nothing means
nothing you just light a candle and you
sing a stupid song and you get a little
piece of chocolate and a dumb present
but Christmas my whole house it looks
like Santa's ass blew up it's like there
are [ __ ] red crit look at this it's
just there's there's it's it's green and
red everywhere there's so much look at
the video this is amazing
I mean these are not I just want to tell
everyone that's watching and everything
these are not my people these people
don't Chris these people don't accept me
this is I am not a part of this explain
what is happening in this this is uh
well I what are they doing this is these
are women hating this is not my people
I'm a sinner to this group because I eat
box right
um right and so they that I'm not a part
of this this is not acidic Jewish men
jumping up and down yes I don't know
what they're doing are they celebrating
Hanukkah maybe it says Hanukkah off to a
hot start this year baby shabbat shalom
Shabba by ASAP Ferg okay listen to the
ASAP Ferg no somebody edited it I think
they're I think they're they're hum
they're going up and down on Hanukkah
candles on their in their aim in their
anus that's what it is yeah that's why
this one's cracked
[Laughter]
um I uh yeah because because you know I
want to teach my kids about you know all
the different holidays because I feel
like Catholicism was just forced upon me
and my kids don't know enough about the
other holidays like she that's good like
I want my daughters to know about
Hanukkah we were telling them about the
menorah and all that that we didn't have
a candle we were missing one day the
candle so we used TT Jerry's dildo
[Laughter]
we used to do that years and years ago
we had and we had my daughter light it
with gloves on
and then but whatever but then my
daughter asked what are the kids in
Kwanzaa get what are the kids in Kwanzaa
get and I didn't know and I told her
because I want her to get it I said they
get the flu shot
because I need her to get the flu shot
so I said they got the flu shot and she
said well if there that's what I want
she wants a Quantum she wants a Kwanzaa
holiday so I told her the little kids on
Kwanzaa get the flu shot
um but we do have information here that
said kids there should be uh two gifts
for kids primarily a book and a Heritage
symbol that teach them about the
beautiful and Rich culture
of of Kwanzaa
so yeah I'm gonna um
I don't know I'm gonna ask Andrew
Schultz how to celebrate Kwanzaa
he's the best laugh in the world it's
this is not this is not Chris's stuff
you know my name my name's Q from The
Jokers
I'm Brian Quinn
um what so do you have what are you
doing tonight
I have I I love that you just went into
that joke you're like so do you like
Feta cheese like it was such a random
question
um I have shows tonight in New York so
you're just going to stay in the city
all day no I'm actually going to go out
to Jersey to my mom's place she's in
she's in Florida for three months so I'm
gonna party it up at my mom's and do
some heroin oh my God yeah and she
snored up her blood pressure medicine
[Laughter]
my mom loves you your mom is is
beautiful yeah she's hot she's like no
she's like legitimately like a hot woman
yeah and she's beautiful she really is
and she is so nice so funny and you know
what I like about I can tell in a minute
of your relationship is you can be you
around her which a lot I can't be the
real me around my mom or dad for that
around your mom around my mom or my dad
I can't that's interesting I can't be me
I I've actually like they know only get
to know the real me when they listen to
the podcast and they're horrified
but yeah but uh the real me it's right
away like that you can have a real
relationship
with your ma you have a relationship
with your mom which which I think is so
rare and special yeah but Chris my mom
is a therapist my mom is an old school
therapist hippie from like the 70s and
eight like so she's gets it right so
that's very rare right uh yeah so I can
basically say anything around her I mean
she's like gets it it's yeah it's it's
one of those things where it it's it's
envious I I because I'm like you know
with my mom like you know the holidays
like you know you can't really curse you
can't say anything well that yeah you
can't even I mean even the fact that I'm
not married and have kids it's like we
you know like she doesn't know like she
thinks they're adopted you know like
she's like oh he wouldn't be having sex
without marriage oh God excuse you were
brought up religious yeah religious
which which is an interesting thing to
have now with my kids where like we're
talking all about Christmas where I'm
teaching them but I also don't want to
like pound religion down their throat
yeah like happen to me that's not a
father Bill joke
um but no but I think that's important
yeah I really do yeah my mom is really
like I'll never forget my mom called me
years and years and years what do you do
when you have a pubic hair wrapped
around your uvula
you re you reach in and and grab it out
yeah okay do you want me to do it
yeah maybe my Starbucks coffee will help
I have a question uh what's your advice
to people who want to come out of the
closet on Christmas isn't the girl on
the Starbucks cup look like Venetia
yes
I think Christmas is a perfect time to
come out to your family is it like again
like would you do it like under the tree
that's what you would have
come I think this is a I think
especially if someone's like really ill
like if someone is in hospice or
something and everyone's around the
person like they're about to die yeah
um I think especially if your family's
really religious like really really like
a Christian family from the Deep South
um where you know uh yeah everyone's
really uptight and someone's about to go
and everyone flies in you know the whole
family haven't seen each other in years
and they're in the hospice together with
masks on like it's just very tense
um you you know just so then you don't
have to make phone calls and emails to
everyone you can get them all together
at one time maybe hire a videographer
yeah
um homeless pimp I'm serious yeah I'd
love to yeah he's he's available you do
all that you have everybody in there you
come out of the closet and you have that
whole meal catered by hellofresh use
promo code hey babe yeah that's great
that's a great idea his number one meal
kit yeah and it would be good to have
someone come come maybe like a gay and
lesbian like we did this at our wedding
like someone who's non-denominational
like who's like a big dice like like an
ambiguous guy yeah that's what I'm
saying who's like are they like you know
someone who has you know like like the
guy who stole this we're all here for a
very important occasion yeah with like a
rainbow like this guy pull up Joe
Biden's luggage guy just like I don't
know if you see like this guy who yeah
it's not me with the shaved head people
keep saying it's me with a shaved head
but like this guy would be good right
here oh that's perfect yeah this is the
guy or person I apologize in ambiguous
yeah it's not a guy I just yeah
I'm offended by what you just said oh I
apologize sorry yes imagine yeah that's
a it's a it's a mermaid
it's uh
she's beautiful
um so okay so anyway
and then in the hospice with the 50
family members
the non-denominational
um person
I'm saying that on purpose person to do
the prayer in front of the family the
person dying
um you know and then have the gay person
this goes out to anyone who hasn't come
out in front of their very religious
family to then say um hi everyone uh and
this is exactly how you should say it hi
everyone
um I it's taken me years to do this but
I wanted to wait until everyone is
together especially during A Moment Like
This
um where you know it's calm and there
especially wouldn't be any arguments or
people wouldn't be able to really you
know lash out because this is very hard
for me right this is about me right now
right I know you know I'm gonna make up
a name I know John is on you know his
deathbed but I need everyone to really
focus because this is my journey right
um and I've been struggling this with
this for years yeah
um I uh I'm John okay no keep going yes
you're the sick one thank you for doing
that so just keep going okay thank you
not to your family okay so everyone
please I know you know
um I know you're here with John but
please
focus on me
this is very hard for me
yes
I have not been able to be who I really
am for years and I've had a suppress
myself
I
I want
I am a gay
woman
I love women
and
I can't help who I am I have felt like
this since the moment I was born
the minute I was born
I have been attracted to girls
and I am not going to change who I am
for anyone
so please accept me
and if you don't I will no longer have
contact with you
I'd like to introduce you to my lover
Stevie
Stevie and I have been together
for two weeks and we're getting married
we have a home 14 dogs 11 cats and a
ferret
and we have matching tattoos of our
vaginas
we
did you just die
why are you smiling no I just can't
no I'm dead
[Music]
that was beautiful thank you and that's
how you do it that's how you set up a
scene and that's what we call scene work
and Chris and I have been practicing
that for weeks do you know that I met
Jessica 12 years ago the very first I
took a stand-up comedy class and Jessica
was the um instructor and that's where
we met and we found love and he's great
at eating puss oh so good that's how he
got into the class I make everyone eat
my [ __ ] yeah I wanted to say that
without laughing I just got in do you
want to take it I'd love to I just got
in there I just got in there and I
started eating I was eating [ __ ] I was
eating ass and um I love him you know I
got a I got on a show at Gotham Comedy
Club with you and um and we've been
friends uh for so long and tell them
tell them what I said what did I say the
day I met you
um uh what what he's gonna be
embarrassed I told him I told him he was
going to be a star
and I I don't say that I I don't think
I've ever said that to anyone
I don't think and I've taught hundreds
of people believe it or not over the
years I taught all through um covid I
taught on Zoom all female comics
I taught it probably a hundred women on
Zoom but I I love to teach
um I actually just did a seminar for 55
comics in DC the other day really I
really love to teach uh it was more
about like the business of comedy and
stuff but I the day I met Chris and he
did some stuff in front of me for an
hour I looked at him and I said you're
going to be a star you're brilliant
because he and you were just starting
but I can see it and it's very rare it's
you know one in a hundred people I mean
it's literally that rare
but I knew right away that you had it
because you do well I you know and maybe
and and and I think that that's coming
to uh fruition now because now I'm you
know I have I potentially have my own
show on the spice Network
um and uh really it's a big yeah and
it's uh and it's a big deal and um I
open I'm opening up for Ronnie Chang all
over the world
um oh my God where like uh we're we're
doing um we're actually going to uh
we're actually going to Kiev we're doing
a show in Kiev oh we're at like a bomb
shelter yes and then I'm listen I know
that it's maybe not popular but I'm I'm
crossing the line and I'm gonna do shows
in Russia as well because I think
Vladimir Putin needs comedy I think if
laughter is the best medicine then
Vladimir Putin needs it as well and I I
just hope you don't get stuck there
because who would they trade you for
me who would I get traded for
um that's a good question who the [ __ ]
would I get traded for I mean well
Brittany Greiner is already out you
wouldn't you might not get traded so
easily no because I'm white I'm serious
I'm not even just saying that yeah no
I'm not going to get traded you're not
so I would not go to Russia but he could
probably work for Russian media I
couldn't you could podcast for them I
think no but I think they would arrest
him and keep him in jail as like a
really good
I wonder if we went to Russia if we went
to Moscow I wonder if they would like
find out who we were and like listen to
some podcasts and put us in jail just
for some of the things we've said about
Russia on the podcast 100 right like you
can't go there I wouldn't I would I
would die in a Russian prison I would
die in any prison an episode ago you
screamed at camera nukas you [ __ ] to
Russia to Putin personally yeah well oh
my God an episode ago
do you
would you is there a place in the world
that you would never go if I yes Jessica
I'll give you five million dollars to go
and just don't say I wouldn't know five
million I don't know if I go to Russia
right now you wouldn't go
I
I'm I would be afraid to go to Russia
would you go to other like would you go
to like um like Antarctica yeah stuff
like that yeah you would go to there
yeah do you think there's pyramids on
Antarctica that's what a lot of people
say
no I believe in a lot of like I believe
no I mean not some of them are so
ridiculous right I mean I believe in in
other like other
life out there I believe in a lot of
stuff but I don't believe in like
ridiculous things like Elvis being a
large you know Tupac being alive no he's
right I don't believe in any of that
[ __ ] he's always watching
look at this here's what here's the gift
I want to get you a Roomba I want to get
you a Roomba because what they're doing
now is they recorded a woman on the
toilet and then it posted the pictures
automatically or Facebook
God the Roomba was going to clean the
floor and it just posted a picture of
her bare ass on the toilet to her
Facebook do you want a Roomba wait I had
some how did it happen yeah how do we
have a camera I believe she was a
housekeeper and she messed with the
settings no and I think it was just
going on auto mode it was just going
going
freaky
they were then sent to scale AI a
startup that contracts workers around
the world to okay so yeah so it's like I
believe in all that like tracking phone
like all that stuff it makes me you know
what I feel though like when people are
like I don't want to give you my social
security number I'm not they already
have it no I know see I kind of feel
like you're ridiculous if you don't want
to give the number up if you don't want
to give your facial recognition
technology it's like they already have
it they already have so just shut up I
agree about you just succumb but this is
the big issue here this is a problem
pimp said he wanted us to read this and
learn about this live on the show face
recognition Tech gets Girl Scout mom
booted from rocket show due to where she
works so pimp so if they want to explain
this they have facial recognition now
MSG has it at uh Radio City and a woman
went with her daughter to go see the
show but she works for a law firm that
is currently suing some part of MSG
so they banned her from the venues so
now the facial recognition picked her
out of the crowd and said she's not
allowed in here she's suing us on
another thing that's crazy how how
that's wild that must have been
specifically out for her though like
well no look see right here it says a
loudspeaker said woman gray scarf
no like she's in a database they have
her her face flat so do they have all
our faces like if you're in a lawsuit
with them like I'm in a couple of
lawsuits that's what I mean you might
not be able to go places now
that's [ __ ] up well I'll just go like
this like a rabbi and you can't get me
that's crazy that is I mean it is
getting to the point do you think in
China they already have a social credit
score where you get scored as a person
and you can like not get jobs not get
allowed into taxis not you know be
allowed in certain areas if your social
credit score is below a certain number
but what is social credit score meaning
like if you like you know did something
bad or like you know [ __ ] up somehow
you get a number from like one to ten
and if it's like they like the
government may give you like a four and
then when you scan into something it's
like in this big National Database
they'll be like oh this person's a piece
of [ __ ] they only got a four on their
social credit wow I think you should
think of as like this is at a venue you
guys would work now what if you get
flagged by their system for saying
something problematic
now you you're not allowed to you know I
mean they can ban you from effectively
anywhere they own if Live Nation goes
you're banned from our stuff you can't
go to a show then I'll go on stage and
do the show like Kanye did Alex Jones
I'll put that thing right over my head
and I'll [ __ ] walk right out there
and I'll say I'll I'll say um you know
that I'm [ __ ] I'm not Chris Stefano
I'm I'm somebody else did you hear
between takes of Alex Jones Show he was
weeping Kanye they would cut to
commercial who was weeping Kanye having
a full mental breakdown you haven't
heard from him in like a week or two now
yeah I was thinking about away a little
bit no we're just starting to ignore him
he's just he's still out there he
released music music got leaked that is
there's there's a new wave of music
coming that I'm calling hate speech
music okay where it's Kanye has a song
where he just repeatedly says the k word
and says why can't I say that anymore
and it's like the chorus and then also R
Kelly came out with the song where he
sings that pedophilia is your opinion on
age consent not my opinion so why am I
in jail for your opinion oh my God God
wild music
well I mean listen 200 years ago I mean
these kings and queens they were they
they had 12 year old wives
maybe R Kelly's a fan of History he
can't even read
that is true allegedly
yeah no it's it's
stupid now I I'm telling you I feel like
Kanye's gonna get hurt you think he's
gonna hurt himself
I feel like no he might lead the next
January 6th
I'm going to the next January 6 dressed
as this I'm dressed as the rabbi I'm
working
I would yes holding up the Tupac sign
I feel like I feel like no you know what
I think God forbid I feel like some
follower of Kanye's is gonna do
something
so it is brought to you by betterhelp
okay I like better help I need better
help we it is online counselors that
they set it up you do it from the
privacy of your own home mental health
can be a real challenge
and you just get set up with a therapist
on Zoom or you know on the computer you
don't have to go to an office there's no
brick and mortar here it's just they set
them up it's got and they they have over
three million people with licensed
therapists they've connected it's
convenient and accessible anywhere and
100 online and it will help you figure
out the cause of therapists what they're
trying to do is help you figure out the
cause of your challenging emotions okay
and then they give you Scope coping
skills and it's great I've been using it
Sal's been using it everybody in this
room uses it everybody uses better help
because it actually works right now if
you go to betterhelp.com that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe you're going to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 off your
first month all you got to do is fill
out a brief questionnaire match you up
with the therapist and then boom bang
boom Bingo boom you got a therapist you
got your mental health in check you got
your coping skills betterhelp.com slash
hey babe
[Music]
sound to Shopify
Bing it's the sound of Shopify
Shopify baby you know we love it here at
hey babe you know that's how we got this
whole business started if you have a
business you need Shopify it makes it
simple to sell to anyone from anywhere
they create an online store in your Vibe
discover new customers and grow the
following that keeps them coming back
I love Shopify thanks to the 24 7
support and free libraries full of
educational content shopify's got you
baby 24 7 support it's so important so
thank you so much we appreciate it go on
try Shopify for free and start selling
anywhere sign up for a free trial right
now at shopify.com hey babe all
lowercase don't put uppercase it's all
lower case
shopify.com hey babe start selling
online today shopify.com slash hey babe
actually I did want to know if you've
ever had to go through your child's
phone
oh yeah you ever have to go through any
of your kids phones I had to do it
um I haven't but my ex has had to do a
lot of stuff like that with my own and
then have a conversation with you about
yeah there's some [ __ ] that you see in
there yeah so you're being a very you're
like a very cool Progressive mom so if
you saw some like hyper sexualized stuff
you wouldn't probably react and start
screaming at them right away well no I
don't react and scream but I mean we
have definitely talked to Isabella about
like the tick tocks and all that stuff
like she cannot watch that stuff anymore
no no no it's insane she starts being
you know they start saying rude stuff
talking back inappropriate
of course you can't do it yeah no no
yeah no same thing with mine like no she
gets she's been you know a bit combative
and oh totally no YouTube no no Tick
Tock nope and she's and when my daughter
was like why can't I have Tick Tock I
was like because it's owned by the
Chinese that's why yeah and you can't
have anything from them because that's
the enemy honey
I'm telling you it's the same thing
[Laughter]
a chopped her head
I [ __ ] stuck chopsticks up her
mother's eyes
oh my God oh my God
oh my God his response is oh my God
it sounds like a like a woman like in
herself oh my God oh my goodness
gracious
chopsticks up her ass at least they're
thin yeah
rubbing Duck Sauce all over my feet
stupid
and then I put an egg roll and it took
us
look at my mouth
oh my god do you gag yes so what is my
little brother
my grandmother used to you loves you my
little brother loves you
laughs
stop I'll come
listen my grandmother once was eating
asparagus oh my God that [ __ ] [ __ ]
she put in the whole piece and she was
so old
she was like
pulled out the whole piece and my
brother my little brother was like 11 at
the time at the gorgeous restaurant and
he went he threw up through all over he
couldn't handle it he vomited
yeah the whole piece she pulled out the
entire at like a very fancy restaurant
imagine when her pee must have smelled
like that night
asparagus P the worst
um
I really don't want to think about my
grandmother's urine
I do
imagine you walked in your grandma was
peeing on my chest and I was if you knew
and I was going on Kelly's not a
pedophile
Jessica remember the time you told me
you got a kidney stone in Alaska I
didn't have a kidney stone at a
gallbladder oh removed was that
terrifying to be honest you want to flip
the [ __ ] out knowing you if I if I get
like a I flew home from England once
because I had like diarrhea because I
thought like I'm gonna get I'm gonna die
of like my Colon's gonna burst and you
were literally this is the best story I
was on it not just the cruise Chris I
was on an all-gay mail Cruise it was so
dramatic oh they were all on I was taken
away by an ambulance and they were all
on their balconies like oh my God
Jessica Kirsten's being taken away in an
ambulance it was so dramatic oh my but
like so okay so when did the pain start
happening were you guys like in the
middle of the sea the the bearings yeah
I was in the middle of Alaska in this
gorgeous cruise ship with thousands of
gay men were you on stage when you felt
the pain I was in horrible pain for a
couple of days and I was like what is
going on this is not normal you were
nervous very
very I did the show and then I was like
this is not okay something's wrong but
you couldn't even eat really no I was
very sick I had horrible pain I just
want to put I just wanted the audience
to understand like when you have to
perform comedy or anything be on stage
for any reason and you're in pain like
that yeah the stripping virus when I
have to strip and I feel like that it's
really bad you never yeah you don't want
to do that especially after you've eaten
asparagus because nobody wants that
because a lot of you girls are not doing
your kegels and you get dripped out I
can't tell you how many times I've got a
lap dance and then I get up I got a wet
chest and
so so I but you get the anxiety yeah you
have the shits and everything forget
about being sick it's compounded with
anxiety think how am I going to get
through an hour of Comedy right now so
you're dealing with that for two days
yeah horrible and then and but it's pain
it's not even like nausea it's just bad
pain and it doesn't stop and you know
and you know when you know something's
wrong like it's not just I have a
stomach virus or I ate something like
something's wrong like it's a whole body
thing right I'm like I
I need to go see a doctor so then I that
night I didn't like anybody on this
Cruise the doctor and they're like
they're like we are but we're also we're
doing Crystal Method of each other's
[ __ ]
yeah
operate right now do you want meth or an
open [ __ ] oh Tupac doesn't want to be
on the show anymore
Tupac's like nope no they're like I'd
help you but I'm a little [ __ ] up
right now
um yeah so okay yeah so I'm like I I
have to go to the dot like it was late
at night one night and I was like I have
to go down to the doctor you I you
obviously no one knows like I for me to
have gone down to the doctor it meant I
was in horrible things I don't I don't
do that forget you're in Alaska so you
have to go it's very very you go to a
doctor and it's a big thing because now
you have to crawl into the igloo no I
went down in the ship doctor I was on C
so it was like three in the morning it's
three a.m
you're kind of like I'm walking down the
hallway we have so much pain in horrible
pain hanging onto the side of the wall
like you're crying almost I am crying
I'm in horrible pain right horrible
right
um and I had only had one minor
operation in my life
hahaha
I love you so much this is my guess
Weird Al Yankovic
so I love you so I'm hanging on to the
walls and I'm like oh my God this is
really I'm I was freaking out I'm a
Jewish girl from New Jersey like it just
I was freaking out freaking out and I
know you're a Jewish girl from New
Jersey but I I'm telling you even though
I've never seen you in pain you can just
it's very obvious when you see Jessica
on stage her power she's a very tough
woman so for her to be going to a
hospital it's like excruciating pain
especially on a ship where they're not
from the United States they were all
foreigners the doctors the nurse like it
just was a lot yeah it was like some
Filipino per like a guy from Guam that's
probably not even really a doctor on the
boat they're like I don't know what the
nurses
they were all they were like hello how
are you they were little people oh my
God they're little people they were like
we represent the doctors
you know he was like can you can you
give me a boost so I could be high level
with your gallbladder
hello how are you yeah so yeah so I um I
walked in and I was like hi um you know
um I need help and I she I was yellow so
I started getting jaundice that's so
sick because because it was like leaking
in your
Liverpool infection I mean a horrible
infection horrible like really I was not
doing okay so they knew this lady didn't
mean she looked at me she said she had
to put me on an IV she had it was
horrible it's horrible she should help
with the pain a little bit the IV well
she put me on an IV and gave me pain
medication and they
um she figured that's obviously I was
not okay and they had to get me off the
ship how far were you from Land were you
guys from Land right now we were going
to a small island called Sitka
um the next day so I was in this
hospital and they got in touch with do
you know Brad locally Brad Logan he's a
communist he's a great person a very
good friend and he was the cruise
director of the of the you know the ship
that week because he's comic and he took
over the organization it was amazing
thank god he's a great guy why is Brad
Pitt there when you Google this is Brad
Logan Brad is the greatest guy he's such
a nice guy and he's hysterical he was
just in the news last week for stealing
Luggage in the world
Brad is hysterical and I gotta tell you
I like Bradley he [ __ ] said
that you don't even know what he did for
me he came right down to to the he he's
been a comic for years he's in La now
but he's from New York you don't know
what he did for me he he came right down
to the hospital down there he was like
it's okay I was hysterically crying I
was petrified they had to get you off
the boat like in a Stretcher yeah but
not only that like you don't know what
he did he went to my room and packed my
[ __ ] like it's like that is so
embarrassing I had like underwear out
like [ __ ] everywhere yeah of course [ __ ]
scenes everywhere [ __ ] in your suitcase
yeah it's [ __ ] all over my room yeah
yeah you peed in all your shoes you had
you had scratch-offs
Brad to homo on it I discharged
everywhere like Brad's yeah lipstick all
over my mirror yeah yeah you ain't happy
in Philly cheesesteaks oh I food
everywhere everywhere you had a small
company I had a big
ziti in my bed like
pillowcases the Korean woman tied up in
the corner you had entenman's crumb cake
just sitting in the toilet bowl because
you eat it right out of the water
I had two [ __ ] in there that I had
just [ __ ] strangled and yes yeah you
skinned the cat
thank you
so what it so he went and packed all my
[ __ ] for me right I mean it was so he's
like don't worry it's okay I'm gonna
take care of you honey like I just and
they called Danielle and they were like
told her what was going on and they're
like she's not okay at high fever I had
like jaundice I mean it was not good it
was not true where you were like this
could like it was 50 50. yes I would not
have been okay yes I had a horrible
infection
you want to give it to me okay
okay here here pimp pimp just in the
middle of the story oh pimp got me a
gift uh for for Christmas and Hanukkah
and here I got you a little something
that's hot yeah right I thought Chris
would look great in it and he's such a
great dad keep telling the story I love
that yeah well I know this is um this is
something that I think um
you know where for the kids
gay men love that [ __ ] I saw it at a gay
sex shop yeah actually yeah this is what
Brad locally found in Jessica's luggage
how do I okay don't kill yourself I got
it on here yeah help him here it is you
might need to take off that beard I
would wear something like that actually
it's fun I wouldn't wear a collar I'd
have someone else wear a collar but I am
your daddy
so oh my God oh my God but that's hot on
you Chris it's kind of fun it's okay so
so yeah go ahead anyway I could go on
and on but no but but there was an
ambulance I had never been in an
ambulance can you believe this and was
that first time I was ever in it was it
on was it was it a real ambulance on a
sled
laughs
they pushed me on a snowball
S
I was in a tiny Island a tiny little
island that had a hospital one little
Hospital a little bit of a tiny hospital
they took me in an ambulance it was so
dramatic and they and they had one
operating room one surgeon the surgeon
was a traveling guy from the Army can
you [ __ ] believe this
on once in my life no he was there of
course because there's only one surgeon
and one operator that's his station I
was in this tiny little operating room
with like a little curtain there were
like little supplies I was freaking the
[ __ ] out of course he was with me I was
sobbing and I I had them this is so
Jewish I had I called my cousin Bernie
how funny is this who's a urologist
who we call for everything everything in
my family and I said Bernie you have to
talk to the surgeon I don't know what to
do I I'm I can't have someone operate
because I had a choice to either do that
or remedevac to Seattle and have a
telecasters right and I would have done
that but I was so sick I was so you just
wanted it to be done no they were like
you really need to get this done like
you're not okay so I was like I don't
know what to do he's like I think you
need to get it done let me talk to him
and he talked to him he's like he's done
thousands of these thousands he's an
army he's an army surgeon he's literally
done thousands you're okay you're safe
and I trust my cousin with my life yeah
and so I had it done and I had to stay
the ship left they left they had to so
they literally they just dropped you off
yeah I was by myself were the gay guys
mad or they understood no I had
performed already so they were like oh
so this ship was anyway yeah that's it
one stop I mean that was one of their
stops was the the island so what happens
if it would have been two days before
like you just happen to I would have had
to be on a helicopter off the show they
would have had to land it on the ship
and get you that's what they do yeah now
would you have to pay for the helicopter
ride
yeah I think so yeah really what the
ambulance run you from a well Bernie
would pay for what the money steals from
you
I don't know
the question I don't
so the guy says everything is going to
be fine the surgeon's great he's a nice
guy he was wonderful
um you know he was into the comedy thing
you know what I'm saying they get like
that he's a really nice job as you were
going under anesthesia he kissed you on
the lips yeah I think he fingered me but
I didn't care that's how he got out your
gallbladder yeah I think he's stuck I
think he stuck his fist UPS inside of me
and Brad Brad took it and put it in your
suitcase
but for some reason my ass was bleeding
but I don't know
so so anyway I was there the ship left
four days I I was very upsetting I was
taught myself for four days in Alaska
your family can't come but that but then
I I flew to Seattle they took very good
care of me and I had a wheelchair the
whole thing the airline and my dad flew
to Seattle with Tim was Tom Hanks there
my dad was my dad was a tough guy we've
laughed about this because my dad was a
business all right Brooklyn guy he was a
great man my dad was great but he was
like come on let's go like and you know
I was sick and he was like let's go come
on get in the [ __ ] you know yeah like
yeah get the best Obama memes
he was a big Trump guy my dad
um I know I I follow him on Facebook
yeah he he flew to Seattle and meet me
and he flew me home and he flew home
yeah did you first class oh yeah good
yeah
United he was a million mile whatever
you know all over the world that that so
that was because that is a nightmare
nightmare to be going through something
like that not only on on you know so far
from home but in the middle of the ocean
to be going through like it probably was
like something you think about all the
time like you have stress from it post
PTSD I'll never I'll I haven't been on a
cruise since and I've been asked to do a
lot of them and those gigs are amazing
those those ones with the gay guys I
mean they're they're probably some of
the best gigs I've ever done because
they they pay well they treat you like
gold you stay in like a sick
I traveled the world with them I've gone
to Greece I probably three times with
that group I've gone all over Europe
I've gone to everywhere I've gone all
over the world with with those groups
with the gay men and that the parties
are the best in the world the best
lighting lasers DJs from all over the
world I mean I've performed with the
biggest stars on those ships I mean
everyone I can't even tell you singers
Comics I mean is there any fights it
sounds like a prime spot for a fight on
a ship like any drug-induced fights no
but I've been on where people have died
and oh oh deed it's been horrific some
of the things do they do do they give
them a Burial at Sea just wrapping
rainbow over or do they ship them to
Seattle they put them in a rocket and
then there's a big there's a big rainbow
yeah no I I they they they uh yeah they
they ship them home it's really yeah you
dive there's so much it's really insane
it's
I mean I'm hoping that hasn't does
hasn't happened a lot in the past couple
of years since I haven't been doing them
but I unfortunately have been around
that did you see that guy who fell off
the cruise ship a couple of weeks ago I
just saw it for 18 hours because he was
drunk as [ __ ] he said really he said he
remembers like 8 p.m and then when he
comes to Consciousness it's like two
o'clock in the morning he's in the
middle of the ocean by himself watching
the boat go away
and he got because he got in trouble for
Vaping he was vaping on the plane right
I was vaping on the cruise yeah on the
deck and then they were and it fell off
the back of it
yeah but again I we said it before but
when the news talks to him they play
b-roll that was captured to him and the
on the dance floor like black out wrong
black out like he's on like he's on as a
gay Cruiser I don't think he can sue I
don't think he can really Sue because he
[ __ ] up yeah at 11 p.m he took a
bathroom break and never came back to
the carnival not always but what yeah I
didn't do I did uh I did Royal Caribbean
and
and uh that's the other one
I did Royal Caribbean I did some of
those they're beautiful like I did some
of the really really upscale
um look at this
um what do you protesters what is this
swarm New York City Library uh protester
swarmed New York City library because
the hosting a drag Story Hour for kids
they don't want the drag story out I
know I love that they think it's going
to end like they're gonna stop doing
them it's also optional what's the
difference then if you don't like it
don't go I I don't know why they think
if they protest it it's gonna stop like
I don't understand what they're thinking
yeah it's so so dumb if you I mean it's
it's it really is like listen we're
living in a world right now stop
grooming kids for sex with I mean look I
mean that guy looks like that guy looks
like all he does is
like you know what's so upsetting and
it's so [ __ ] enraging
do you know how many people I know that
were molested by priests and rabbis
yeah it is so [ __ ] uh like I can't
yeah I'm so sick of I and it's not just
that side it's also like the ultra
liberals that attack me I'm I'm and I
I'm you know like the people like I'm
being attacked I get attacked on Tick
Tock all the time who gets very
sensitive with my jokes yeah so I'm not
saying it's like it's just stop
doing it like just everyone leave each
other alone like just [ __ ] focus on
yourself I don't get it I guess I'm just
I don't but I think people are really
sick in the head like I they I don't
think I know that and you know what
happens too as I think like like they'll
say big protest but it's like five
people you know what I mean no I know
they always don't know the media you
know the media will be like I know uh
you know they had con you know that
something will happen like look at all
these comments and it's like four tweets
I know they like to like blow things out
of proportion uh too
um but yeah I mean this guy right here
that says stop grooming kids for sex is
probably the scariest person I've ever
seen in my life he probably agree he
probably is a child molester I want to
eat asparagus now oh I love asparagus
what's your favorite vegetable
ah you know I actually love vegetables
really do you I love them so that's a
cup of Fruit today berries strawberries
and mangoes because I live with Puerto
Ricans yes see I love fruit too I've
always love fruit and vegetables I I my
favorite vegetable number one
oh my God broccoli I love broccoli so
good
I thought that when you asked me
broccoli it's one of the top ones
I like I personally like I like peas I
love peas I love corn but snow peas are
regular mushy peas no I love mushy Peas
I went to
um England with James matter and our
good friend James matter and all I want
to do is eat fish and chips but he's
allergic to peas so I couldn't have the
mushy peas because he would go into some
kind of [ __ ] peanut allergy oh my god
did you love doing England I can't wait
to go it was amazing England Scotland uh
well I didn't do Scotland this time but
England and Ireland
unbelievable I want to go back Scotland
and Wales is what I'm going to do next
what'd you call me no I'm joking hi
do you ever go to Australia yes I did
the Melbourne Comedy Festival going to
Australia supposedly in June Australia
and New Zealand you're gonna have you
ever been no you're in New Zealand no
but just Australia yes and I had the
best time I went for a month you were
there for one month but before him I had
you know only uh you only had one child
yes Zoe so I went for like three and a
half weeks it was amazing with them or
you went alone now alone it was amazing
did it cause fights that you got to go
to Melbourne and your partner didn't go
get to go to Australia to stay home and
take care of the baby I'm not projected
a little bit but it
it was incredible you're gonna flip out
it's amazing then the crowds are great
the people are great it's beautiful
there well I because I wanted to be like
go with someone like oh like bring
Jasmine but it's like it's like twenty
thousand dollars to get there like you
can't like I can't it's so expensive
there yeah they're flying within the
country it's like I I can't I can't
bring anybody Chris everything is like a
I I don't want to say the exact I
remember a Coca-Cola was like six
dollars like it's crazy a can of Coke
like it's crazy because everything's
just it's just it's a fortune
everything's important but it's it's
really one of the most incredible you've
been there vanity into Australia
and Melbourne it's I remember going to
grab a coffee at Starbucks like with a
muffin and a coffee it was like 15 bucks
oh I want a muffin but it's not Saturday
um wait a second and then flop like from
Melbourne to Sydney it's like flying
from like New York to L.A right like
you're like it's not that far it was
like an hour or so really I feel like
they're on the other sides of the
country because Australia's big it's not
just like it's like a huge country you
just stayed in one place though I did
you didn't travel all around the country
no because I did the festival there so I
did a lot of shows yeah
um but it was really with any other
American comic so you didn't know
anybody there James adobian yeah yeah
yeah and um and I can't remember I can't
remember who the other comic was it was
a long time ago but I really Bill Cosby
yeah yeah
I think
he made you forget
if I was drugged the whole time I don't
remember what happened he woke up with
an asparagus in your ass
everything's always in the ass
you're doing them I see you're doing in
Seattle the more theater yes that
theater is amazing you've done it and
you by the way the flyer that McKinley
Cox made for that the the McKinley some
of the guy that makes our flights that
Sleepless in Seattle flyer is hysterical
yeah I think the best best one I think
it's the best one he ever made I mean
the way he put you on it's just amazing
yeah Jessica Pearson Sleepless in
Seattle more theater when is that show
it's in uh I think it's in the air I
think it's in 2028. there it is April
yeah it's April 1st 2012. yes April
Fool's Day yeah there it is I don't know
where it is is it no you can go on my
Instagram it was just posted today yeah
that fly yeah guys I have so many shows
where they can find you yeah Jessica
there it is that one because I just
thought like it just yeah it's great
look at this look at this picture look
at this
isn't that unbelievable it's Seattle
April 1st that's just
first of all it's like a true nice
theater it's right down by the water I
love it I can't wait three tears and
that's your first theater that's my
first theater game like that headline
like that's just like four years I'm
going to look 24. and that theater is on
you're gonna have a great time there
you're gonna sell it out go see it just
sold a lot of tickets already I guess uh
yeah no no it's it's gonna sell out
you'll probably add one yeah um and and
it's amazing
um and you know it's uh yeah isn't that
incredible it's amazing flyer look at
the one the next one yeah because I
already sold out a show in Oregon
he's amazing it's amazing important yeah
this is the second show who added an
important the first one sold out who was
he making who did he make you
um I don't know do you know who it is it
feels like Portlandia like a Portland
yeah yeah okay that's pretty
unbelievable yeah he's great what else
so what other shows do we have I want to
make sure people don't see us in Boston
Boston here we go
Cincinnati Columbus Denver Phoenix
Austin oh you're going to be there for
moon tower yeah not moon tower actually
I mean Austin during South by Southwest
but not Nashville yeah Salt Lake yeah
you're gonna have a great time everybody
go uh go to Jessica's show
um go to her site
um and thank you so much I love you so
much you know how much I love you so
much you're brilliant you really are and
you guys are great I appreciate it yeah
thank you Sal we'll see you guys January
first week of January the New Year this
the last episode of 2022 we ended it
with a bang with Jessica Kirsten I'm
going to end it by bang Jessica I can't
wait oh I love it and uh I'm gonna
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna hit you right in
the gallbladder
come on oh [ __ ] okay
and uh we love you guys so much we will
be back with Sal
um January where Sal and I have some
confirmed dates to start filming uh next
week so I just got word from his family
that he rose from the dead he's the new
Jesus he's out of the coffin and he'll
be here next week I love you guys taking
up at Bloom Cafe thank you for a great
2022 go see Jessica on the road go see
me on the road go see Sal on the road
um and have a good time we'll see you
January 6th
[Music]